you know probably let's give a shout out
though South I'm proud of you here
getting set up for the big event this
morning at Wine Library who hooked us up
at this audio my other man Skyler Skyler
Skyler I though we're proud of you we're
thankful awesome alright good
later stoppable
[Music]
would you like hummus broussard what is
that yeah you know okay hey vlog so here
we are Wine Library I haven't been at
why my brain said 8 a.m. on a Saturday
in many many years doing the event the
Q&A session a lot of fun super fun to be
back in the stomping grounds and let's
see what's up you see what we can do
Fran what what goes on here if anything
at any time
what goes here I feel like this needs to
be smarter I think this needs to be
smarter back to my old school
you could take a boy from the liquor
store you can't take the liquor store
away from the boy you need help
memories feelings the feelings I mean
this building is especially interesting
because it's a second it's the building
that we built right but it wasn't super
easy it took way too long so I have a
funny vibe towards it amazing but like
sometimes like this [ __ ] whiner and
took I'm here too long kita hey guys
it's Gary Vaynerchuk I'm here at the
Wine Library and I'm super excited to be
talking to you because corporate gifts
and the bottom line is there's not a
single wine club out there that even
remotely can hang with this so cool well
thank you so much for coming this is
super fun it's funny me and Dirac we're
joking right before saying we do so many
events and a lot of times people say
well how many people were there and
we're like 100 or 200 but if this is
what 85 looks like I think we've been
under estimating every event you know I
lied so thanks for coming out this early
you know it's funny when I was putting
this together I'm like you know what
let's let's organize this at 8:00 a.m.
on a Saturday let's see who's really
committed so I'm enjoying that part
listen you know at to that point if if
you're gonna be here at 8 a.m. on a
Saturday then I think the far majority
of you have a whole lot of context of
Who I am and a lot of my schpeel right
so instead of repeating stuff that I
think you you can hear online or you're
probably really super close to I think
we can really go pretty hardcore into QA
and so do you guys feel collectively
like that might be the right way to go
all right cool we'll do that and then
like if I want I'll find things to say
along the way so I mean look with two
hours I'm pretty sure we might be able
to get to everything here though
actually I'm totally I wish Tyler was
here but four DS there's only 10 people
and takes an hour and a half and he
always gets mad at me so why don't we
why don't we start raising hands let's
go let's got a question you know back
with the Hat what's your name David
so yeah cool so I think that there's a
lot of ways to go about it
I think that you've got to recognize
that there's a lot of people who never
in their lives will build a business
with three locations that's profitable
or you know not sinking so I don't think
under estimating yourself because of
your age is the right strategy I think
the most concerning thing for me is the
first words out of your mouth are faster
you know and I think and I think I talk
about patience in a lot of ways but I
don't talk a lot about it from I talk
about it more from you've got to be
patient to get to the success things
instead of you've got to deploy patience
pretty much the entire way right I mean
I'm always stunned by people who reply
to me pushing patience and replying in
the comments or DM or email of like easy
for you to say rich guy right which
which is super funny for me because I
think I'm probably deploying the
greatest patience of my life right now
like if you really understand the
economics of my day to day you know the
fact that I'm even operating vaynermedia
is me deploying in an enormous amount of
patience I'm running a very non
profitable not interesting business I'm
meeting a lot of [ __ ] on a daily basis
client services at the scale that we're
at at 150 million dollar level and 800
employees it's just not a fun business
when I can just I mean look look at the
economics around something like this
right or the things that you see like
for DZ's far more me than vaynermedia I
mean I can live my I can live right now
and make 15 to 20 million dollars a year
which is more money than I make enjoying
myself and just being garyvee so I think
I think the thing that you need to think
about is it's working but like the thing
that will hurt you is if you have too
much ambition locked up in the amount of
locations yeah you know locations remind
me of likes like for some reason people
care about how many likes and followers
they have even though it has no proxy to
the reality of their situation and and I
think locations are very similar look at
this this is the only location of Wine
Library right so like you know I think
one thing that I spend a lot of time on
and again an audience that I think
understands me deeper so I'm gonna try
to go into a little bit of a different
angle like almost everything I talk
about is me giving advice that I'm
actually living you know I might just be
further along in the path but it's
everything that I I never try to guess
and the way I learn is by doing and so
almost everything I talk about is
predicated on what I'm doing have done
and will continue to do and so I would I
would tell you to slow it down yeah you
know like let it slow down you know one
way to really lose is to get out of
control right like once you start
learning how to drive you know when you
were a kid and like alright let me see
if I can go 80 that's when [ __ ] gets you
know dangerous right and so I would tell
you that it's not about somebody else
and it's not about you know the best way
to get bigger is to be calculated and
smart about it and so my intuition is if
you've gotten it this far this early
then you saw something and you've
executed better than others and you've
taken advantage of whether it's your
area or region or digital marketing or
or hustle or passion or a million other
things that could be but I don't think
faster is a good model I think I think
proper and calculated make sense yeah
cool questions go ahead
with time management yeah I worked the
95 I'm 28 I still live at home with mom
yep
stood alone that the whole night yep I
really try not to make excuses and I'm
grateful that my mom is letting me get
on my feet
totally how do I get past that hold okay
I'm tired from coming home to the 95
friends are calling wine and watch the
game yep I get it now I get it how do I
do the 72 I am and still be yeah there's
a lot of different things here first of
all you should audit your 9 to 5 I would
make it as easy as possible like there's
an arbitrage to be productive at your
9:00 to 5:00
a lot of people when I wrote crush it I
mean this is now 2009 this 7 p.m. to 2
a.m. thing it's been around for a while
which is crazy
I mean I've answered this email so many
times it's been amazing how good this is
one of my favorite pieces of advice I
know I'm building it up but it's
actually crazy the amount of people that
I've been able to sit tell who've gone
from making fifty eight thousand seventy
three thousand one hundred ninety
thousand in their nine-to-five to from
57 to 51 from 73 to 60 from one ninety
to ninety because what they did was they
figured out what they really needed to
even just barely live but their
nine-to-five got way easier they just
literally some of them literally would
go and work at like Saks Fifth Avenue on
the sales floor and have 11 hours you
know 9.8 our ships where retail is a
good one right now go work retail
nobody's coming in and you can be on
your phone and work
right I love my job you don't love it
more than what you want to happen
correct the end right life's about
choices brother there's nothing else to
say
I don't you know this is where it gets
important this is the you know I love
saying bye and hurry cuz it is if you
love it so much then you wouldn't be
here so you don't love it enough so [ __ ]
that got it yeah like make a little less
or make more just make it something that
doesn't take up your brain and energy so
that your [ __ ] the the bigger issue
now is that you were so bored for eight
hours that it's tough to restart not
that you're out of energy I mean it
that's the answer it's not so easy to
execute I get it I get it
especially when debt is compounding with
that interest like this is why I'm just
I really you know dude its I don't I can
tell it's not excuse it's a fundamental
issue that I'm trying to put a lot of
pressure on as one person and hope it
builds momentum the thought of going to
college and and collecting six figures
of debt in the way what college does for
you in return in today's world is wrong
it's not there's just nothing else to
say it's fundamentally wrong especially
if it's not a layup
two to six figure job listen you want to
go and you're gonna be a consultant at
Bain & McKinsey or Goldman Sachs because
it's Harvard and Stanford you can sell
me a little bit but that's a small
percentage and if you're an entrepreneur
now [ __ ]
I mean Babson is a great entrepreneurial
school but it's the minor leagues to
real life entrepreneurship so my answer
is simple just say like round this out
likes about choices right and like
they're hard and it's about patience
what I'm telling you to do is probably
like a good solid seven-year mapping
game plan and for you you're like [ __ ]
man 30 like like it's not feeling good
to be 28 at my mom's house the [ __ ] is
Gary talking about 35 here's what I'm
talking about
life is long it's good C's okay let's
move it back and I'll set up there for
the last half an hour this way we just
good hey blog good day on a Saturday got
to see a bunch of people good to be back
in the stomping grounds super fun super
fun I was my favorite part of the whole
talk so you talked I looked over a
little bit in the ayah and I've watched
a go